[Music]
in water haters news
hey that's Gina yeah Gina hates water
well I never PP water either oh well now
I just I can't swim so as far as the
shower goes like yes I hate getting my
hands wet when I wash dishes and then I
don't want to die in the water what
about um I was thinking drinking one Oh
drinking water she's afraid to drink
water swim in a hot tub do you like hot
tub you don't this one is just three
feet I don't know anything could happen
what if I submerged falls asleep also
can't get my hair wet it's just an all
around what is that right yeah David you
said it's all [ __ ] frizzy curl it
[ __ ] it all up dude when you go to like
pool parties with all like the black
homies issue all the girls do not put
their hair in the water they're right
above it they chilling next to it but
you'll never see them dip their [ __ ]
hair in it that's just expensive as [ __ ]
we looking bad but we dry it
I love with David explains black girl
stop less expensive man that's a [ __ ]
process dude mm-hmm
submitted by Bobby Bowsher Bobby Boucher
[Laughter]
that's white people culture okay Boucher
actually in the movie yeah waterboy yeah
one way hot girl haters explain why they
refuse to drink water
what's a hydro haters water heaters yeah
people who only want to drink some kind
of sugary drinkers you started drinking
water oh that's so now these people like
they hate water the taste or the lack of
taste water is so [ __ ] good for you oh
my god it's like Joe never laughs dude
this [ __ ] right here changed my [ __ ]
life cuz it is good for your taste so
good to know water is really good one
person it's fine good oh it's so good
right for you
like crazy nutty I'm so yeah do you
remember the last time you broke this
way [ __ ] Nicky don't you want some
water damn straight I do oh okay wait
ice-cold water yeah it's not sex related
when was the last time you broke a sweat
sex-related anytime nikki buys plants I
have to go downstairs and take all the
[ __ ] plants upstairs and there's
usually like 75 involved you know when
you're down there you [ __ ] [ __ ] out
of her I guess the car steps easy this
little tiny plants yeah I'm [ __ ] on
half the car windows all the leaves
coming down to [ __ ] like a [ __ ]
Japanese war movie and I've sent a
cherry blossom that's it carries like a
grasshopper yeah yeah that's why Gary
the grasshopper now stall his color
because he had a witness that [ __ ] all
the time I'm gonna get a little sample
of lips maybe like when Nicki's cat dies
which I hope never happens right so I'm
just like okay this will be only a
tester oh the ground how long do
grasshoppers oh yeah a couple days no
apparently not long this cat's lived for
like two months so I'm like oh boy is he
just like a shell of himself though he's
dead he's just I think so and he barely
[ __ ] even moves at all I don't know
these Hydra haters I'm just talking
about their experiences and why they
hate their experiences so for example
this one girl her name is Laurie she
created the dating app cheeked I bet
you're her [ __ ] vagina smells like
[ __ ] oh yeah oh yeah so she's not going
down there I don't drink that much water
and I pee all the time hey well you also
waste 62 pounds this bottle of water to
you versus Timmy that's hot it's like
one and a half of your stomachs yeah
okay pretty much water cuz it's clear
now because I drink so much water and
and if you're not peeing every hour
you're actually being very much I mean a
lot want to know a lot because like I've
been here and I'm wearing a romper today
and y'all know like when you have on a
romper you got to take it all up if I
was in y'all's bathroom basically
butt-ass naked feeling
yeah and I've already peed like twice
man we don't gotta brag about it you
guys haven't peed yet [ __ ] peasant
[ __ ] simpletons good oh yeah so
there's Laurie chick so she's saying
that she got hospitalized three times in
the past 20 years for dehydration okay
yeah and she's saying that her skin must
be terrible like really oily skin the
peas Orange oh she just hates water that
much she rather die pretty much painful
all she's gotta do is do [ __ ] water
right and get that [ __ ] water flavor
[ __ ] yeah that's what some of these
people are saying so some like this
other person or a lemon infuse it with
different fruit folders they're saying
that lemon doesn't really work for them
but most of these people are saying that
those like water gatorade infusers yeah
that is the only way they can drink
water perfect do it yeah but they're
saying that most of these people are
they just like since they were kids they
could never get past oh they can drink
it their parents never [ __ ] beat the
[ __ ] out of them yeah that's damn
straight yeah like this one person was
complaining about how you just hate how
slimy it feels going down his throat and
like do you ever drink anything ever
yeah he's like yeah when I drink squirt
it doesn't do that
yeah like bubbly like I guess they like
he likes the carbonated look at the
mineral water or like the club soda yeah
yeah it'll coins no yeah that's so drugs
yeah then this other person was like I
hate water especially with straight out
the tap because tastes very nobody likes
any you yeah moldy tape never had that
Kirkland site parkland is really good I
was talking [ __ ] about heavy on yeah
whatever I understand everyone's not
that y'all never had Sparkletts
sparkless comes out of the well any
other
oh yeah you know what else comes out of
the well dead people do [ __ ] that I'm
like my kirklands you know it comes out
of the tap water [ __ ] arrowhead dude
I'm always disappointed by that one that
in Dasani I'm always like this song is
the worst yeah I won't be thirsty really
you think this shot is the work
arrowheads way worse that's pretty bad
but this on is number one and the top
four minerals right we're gonna drinking
it you decide yeah it's good I can't do
it mineral water no it's not yes dude
it's bottle by coca-cola bro I drank
yesterday turn on the spigot tastes like
fresh yeah it's like old Fiji water to
me tastes fresh because of the brand
name because it's square model I'm like
I'm paying more for this pretty drab the
boss water box box water and like I hate
it because I hate their marketing it's
like box waters better I could taste the
cardboard I can't taste the carb oh yeah
you can dude what he was like a card
would water filter because that's the
first thing I tasted what happened go
click she's throwing up gang signs what
did you think about it TIFF not being
able to taste cardboard explains why she
likes frozen pizza cardboard in the
frozen pizzas I mean I think she gave
you you get that same look to Steve
right now what where did that come from
are you jealous she's telling Joe I'm
talking about cardboard the relation
we're talking about water so she can't
taste box water we're talk about water
but he's talk about box Pete's a
cardboard so I'm a box flavor
yeah the box flavor hello and they're
always on a square of cardboard always
you're not eating there Jonah
I want to cover the party please frozen
please I don't even say the word some
Koopa can I say the word out loud no I
said Raja we got that artisinal Digital
or no [ __ ] though that [ __ ] though look
what you did
look what you did now we can't talk
about water you mean - no it's [ __ ]
just said that there was some people
commenting that they thought that I got
paid every every time we mentioned
DiGiorno - and she also said that they
thought that you get one dollar every
time which tells me that they're little
kids she says it she says it ain't I'm
just kidding eight dollar across 200
episodes good love it get yourself a
pizza now - yeah pretty much
all right but anyway we're talking about
water here this other one she's saying
that when she was in Girl Scouts that
she went camping and she's filled up her
whole can see with water she went on the
on his really long hike at the end of
the hike her canteen was still full of
water and all the other girls with empty
she was like oh I could do drink this so
yeah sometimes people just have a very
bad association with water they just
can't drink it this is got problems
mm-hmm like one of them she did mention
how her pee is like bright yellow or not
bright yellow but like dark yellow oh my
god that's disgusting I might have
mentioned this before but I had a
roommate in Riverside when we moved to
those like college college apartments he
took a piss and then he asked me goes yo
can you can you come to the bathroom
real quick and I was like hey this year
he looked like this okay
okay and I looked at it it was like
[ __ ] reddish brown like this
are you drinking water falls right out
of ya so I asked him I was like nah man
I was like you need a drink water he
goes I haven't drank water since I was
like a little kid I was the [ __ ] do you
mean I was like dude if you notice that
what do I drink all the time I was like
are you tell me right now you only drink
cactus cooler
drink cactus cooler everyday until
college anyway he gave anyone see that's
why it's all me cactus cooler and these
are all fake tea is my conspiracy buzz
thing how can a man live off a nothing
but cactus cooler because it's mostly
water thank you the human body is
[ __ ] amazing there's like 400 pound
people 600 even 600 pound people live in
and there [ __ ] live in they are and
they're getting I could watch the show
is just people getting cut out of their
houses have you ever like gone to a
doctor before and you got a pee in a cup
and you see like how clear your pee is
and you walk out of the bathroom like
pregnant like every time I had to go to
my doctor's appointment you have to pee
in a cup every single time because I
have to test like all whatever levels
and then you put it in this like this
like box that opens up on the other end
for the technician to get it and start
testing it so I'd open it in the resort
you'd line of it and how to compare mine
to theirs I'm like oh you guys some
nasty [ __ ] you gotta have that good
[ __ ] pee man but he now drinks a lot
of water so I don't want any [ __ ]
that they can't do it either cuz he gave
it up for Lent but the first two weeks
that he was doing it he could barely get
out of his room because he was so
caffeine sugar addicted Wow
he would be in his room and he had
[ __ ] migraines he couldn't open up
the blood he was just laying there cuz
what's wrong give me the cat's cooler
man you get it I suck you [ __ ] dick
I would just go by it ya know you're so
[ __ ] up yeah he I mean he gave it up
though even without all the peer
pressure around him you know cuz I drink
that [ __ ] it's so funny he had to give
up gag this grass is so funny to me well
I was able to drink more water when I
got pregnant cuz I said I was staying
away from soda and stuff and so I forced
myself to drink more water and that's
when I finally discovered to love dude
man this [ __ ] will clear up your [ __ ]
skin you pimple [ __ ] I didn't keep up
with that for a long time until now I'm
better not the excess oil produce
production that only get solved by four
tours of accutane which I know someone
who did who you lose me
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]